mornings of drought in England a citizen
next month the environment agency has
released a statement following urgent
drought talks that have been happening
today it says people across the country
have been urged to use Water Wisely to
protect water supplies and the
environment during the current period of
prolonged dry weather nowhere in England
is currently considered to be in drought
and most water companies are maintaining
good Reservoir storage for summer demand
they go on to say if further measures
are required temporary use bans more
commonly noses of course the hose pipe
ban and that will be determined by
individual water companies and drought
permits and drought orders by the
environment agency and defra
respectively it goes on to say however
recent abnormally high temperatures have
exasperated conditions resulting from
lower than normal rainfall so far this
year in many parts of England can't
remember the last time we had proper
ranking you and the statement goes on to
say that met office forecasting
um is showing potentially several more
dry weeks ahead taking us well into
August particularly in the South and the
east of the country the EA and the
environment agency and water companies
are now enacting the early stages of
their well-rehearsed and publicly
available drought plans and they are
calling on anyone to do their bit in
managing water use
that is what we have for the environment
agency a rather lengthy statement there
and we've just picked out the highlights
of it for you after those emergency
talks today at the UK of the early
stages of drought but as they said not
officially in drought just yet we'll
keep an eye on that situation here on
Sky News of course well Skies Sadia
Chaudhary has been at Brent Reservoir in
Northwest London for us today
here at this Reservoir it does look like
we've got plenty of water but locals
here say that it's usually much Fuller
it's also about the the weather that is
being forecast more dry spells coming up
um and so that is what's causing this
concern of a drought coming up and
that's why there are these crisis uh
talks happening right now and the last
time we had a drought was just in 2018
so not that long ago but the one
probably a lot of people remember is the
one of the 1970s which was the
hydrological drought that's the similar
to the one that they're being that
they're discussing today and that
happens when there is when there are
consecutive seasons of unusual weather
which is what we've been having of
course if you remember the last few
weeks the um the hot weather we've seen
fires breaking out in places that
usually weren't prone to fire yesterday
I was speaking to some fire Crews at the
hankley common fire who said that the
drizzle that we're seeing we had some
drizzled overnight and this morning and
also yesterday they said that's just not
enough we need a lot more rain to
restore the the conditions back to what
it's meant to be and to be able to save
off a drought and these crisis talks
taking place right now between
government ministers the environment
agency water companies and the national
farming Farmers Union is all aimed at
trying to find ways to protect our water
resources and talks are happening about
what we can do as well we know that
southern water for example has already
applied for a drought license over a
river in Southampton and that is one of
the things that could come out of that
is a hose pipe band now earlier in the
summer when we had that heat wave we had
those Cobra meetings and during that
hose pipe bands were were discussed
whether or not we should have a hose
pipe ban at the time government
ministers told us that it wasn't being
considered because water supply was fine
but we know what happens when there is
intense heat there's there's a lot of
pressure on Water Systems we saw those
burst water mains on the Isle of shepi
which meant that some some people were
without water for three days and you
know Sky News was there covering that we
saw the impact that that has on local
communities so a lot of advice was
already been has already been given to
people about reducing water usage hard
to do on very hot days but just to be
mindful of of things like uh filling up
inflatable pools in your back Garden for
example so hose pipe band's one of just
one of the many things that might come
out of today's meeting